we're the California Highway Patrol
this job is crucial is without us out
there come on get hard California
Highway Patrol I think they have some
crooked cops it want you to go on the
inside fell in the cover within the
department at all we let you with a
rookie named John Baker tell my plan
francis llewellyn poncherello are the
first two female names Johnny like you
hear made me mad he is really handsome
you've had 23 surgeries and you can ride
a motorcycle I'll give you that
yes ma'am like a mother what's up I'm
John poncherello awesome man we're
partners let's kick this off with the
real a nice Oh - you're homophobic or
whatever that's cool no no no no no
anything I'm home now Baker Baker you're
screwed
pretty badass you know suited up for
battle or looking like VPS ever before
go Brown this job is my one shot at
saving my marriage what are you wearing
my uniform it's like you're three beers
too intimate almost tough motorcycle cop
I got no emotion wish you job trying to
30 cop second
you're FBI yep we need to focus
are you kidding me right now I look like
powerless when it comes to yoga panting
get you out of this park now you have a
visible erection you think you can ride
with that I don't know we don't know who
this department is in on this we're like
jay-z and Beyonce your rider diver I'm
Jay Z you uppity your fight you gotta
legitimately funny we have a suspect
head-on the victory nasty I will shoot
out damned nap I need to get into some
warm water and I gotta carry you there I
saved your life yeah I knew you were
gonna bring it up where me
his base plan might no no no no there's
no concept I could've swore I felt
either your nose or your lips I might've
been like a little bit of contact
you